Marc Antoine Lebray qui est avec nous
merci marcanttoine c'est bon je
mesfilles j'ai pas besoin de VOUS he ça
va alors pour commencer on va prendre
des nouvelles de notre président de la
République c'est quoi votre programme en
ce moment Monsieur Hollande
oui je
bonjourouna je vous le dis solellement
j'ai pris une grande résolution dès
demain je me mets au sud au
cul par que comme dès que je fais un
truc ça marche pas bah je fais plus rien
du coup pour m'occuper j'ai joué à GTA 5
mais j'ai perdu direct j'ai essayé les
Sims mais ils sont tous morts j'ai
essayé le puissance 4 mais même à
puissance 1 je perds c'est marrant d'ù
le coup de génie merci
Cyril comme au Sud auocul je joue contre
moi-même ben je suis sûr de gagner ah
c'est très bien ça mais mais vous ça va
sinon parce que je vous sens moyenah je
dirais qu'à part qu'il a rien qui marche
que personne peut me sentir que j'ai la
loe et qu'il m'arrive que des trucs
pourris ça va d'accord disons que
justeque ma courbe de Somme est
inversement proportionnelle à ma courbe
de popularité voilà c'est ça monsieur
Anou j'ai grave le seum il a grave le se
alors ce soir sur M6 il y a Stéphan
Plazza qu'on aime beaucoup qui présente
maison à vendre et en exclusivité il
vient nous parler de son émission
bonjour Stéphane bonjour
Cyr alors moi je suis ravi d'être là
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous j'ai dégoté un bien exceptionnel un
six pièces pas cher du tout en plein
centre de Paris pour un très bon prix
net vendeur regardez la photo Cyril ah
bah oui acheter un puzzle c'est le seul
moyen d'avoir six pièces sans se ruiner
à Paris non et de l'acheter pour un bon
prix net vendeur ah oui quand même ah
oui quand même ah
oui
alors on on on va prendre des nouvelles
aussi de notre confrère Antoine de cône
bonsoir bon ch Cyril on peut en fait
dire qu'en ce moment les audiences du
Grand Journal feraient le bonheur du
commandant cousteaud tellement elle
plonge profond j'ai pourtant essayé de
m'inspirer de votre émission en effet
avec Natacha polinii j'ai une jeune
femme avec une grande gueule une
coiffure étrange et qui raconte
n'importe quoi bref l'équivalent des nor
Malagré
plus Valérie BIM plus Isabelle Bosque ah
oui quand même ou ça na pas suffi pour
aller plus loin j'ai donc demandé à mon
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel apti de se
rapprocher dans ces analyses politiques
de votre Jean-Michel à savoir
Jean-Michel ber et je pense que nous
sommes sur la bonne voie bon va très
bien p p p p je dirais qu'en ce moment
l'économie française est assez ratatinée
comme
mAb par ailleurs la croissance est assez
flappie comme
matb très la seule solution reste donc
de la stimuler très fortement comme
matub voilà mon cher Antoine j'ai donc
fait de mon mieux pour que l'audience se
redresse enfin comme M la courbe de
popularité de François Hollande vous
avez l'esprit mal
placé alors on a également avec nous
parce qu'on passe à quelque chose de
plus glamour vous le savez ce weekend
c'était l'élection de Miss France et on
a voulu savoir ce que jeun di de
fontener bien sûr avait pensé de
l'émission
oui
je l'adore C c'est simple j'ai
détesté j'ai trouvé l'émission
horriblement vulgaire vous savez comme
je déteste la vulgarité cyil en plus
dans le jury il y avait cette [__]
de Valérie B qui montre sa schneek à
tout le
monde
à la moindre occasion non mais vraiment
ça manque de refidement en plus la
nouvelle Miss France elle est pas
féminine pour un sou c'est bien simple
on dirait Miss trance oh non ressemble à
kunchita je sais plus comment kunchita
GEG là non mais oh elle est très belle
ce genre de vulgarité vraiment je
supporte pas excusez là Camille
franchement vous êtes magnifique je vous
le dis alors il y a Franck du Bosque
aussi qui est là
salut tout le monde non tu n'as pas rêvé
c'est bien moi Frank du Bosque ou
devrais-je dire Mister France mieux
Mister Monde voire Mister
galaxie d'ailleurs à l'élection de
Mister Galaxy j'ai croisé un trou noir
et bien je l'ai rebouché avec ma
ququette
Jean-Claude calme-toi
Jean-Claude
calmetoi
bien mer qu'on retrouve au théâtre d
janvier